marijuana in some form is legal in 30
states and Washington DC but it's still
outlawed by the federal government so
that's causing problems with Canada
where marijuana is completely legal some
Canadians who cross the border in places
like Washington State are now being
kicked out of the US as John Blackstone
reports they're not smoking pot they're
investing in it more than 30,000 people
across the u.s. Canadian border here in
blaine washington every day for most
travelers it's a trouble-free experience
but for some Canadian businesspeople
that seems to be changing it doesn't
look like I'll be entering your country
for well maybe never and certainly not
for a long time banned for life and for
life Sam's naima is a Vancouver Canada
based venture capitalist who's been
investing in everything from tech to
telecoms for over 30 years
recently he put a few hundred thousand
dollars into legal American cannabis
companies in May when he attempted to
drive across the border he was flagged
for secondary inspection and questioned
for four hours to my shock and horror I
was told that I was deemed to be
inadmissible to the United States
because I was assisting and abetting in
the illicit trafficking of drugs they
never asked whether I'd consume
marijuana the only thing that they're
interested in is that I've been an
investor in us-based cannabis companies
what's it like to be banned banned for
life from the United States I was
shocked I couldn't believe that anyone
is peripherally involved with these
companies as an investor could possibly
deem to be assisting an abetting it is a
huge regulatory overreach not only they
shocked they're scared American
immigration attorney Lynn Saunders says
he's seen at least a dozen cases like
this in the past few months at this land
crossing as well as at airports in
Vancouver and Edmonton in the prior 15
years that he's practiced law on the
border he'd never seen one you're being
barred because you're getting paid
through drug money even though it's
marijuana and might as well be cocaine
or heroin these are not people who have
criminal convictions these are not
people who I you know are
terrasaur threat united states the new
recreational cannabis regime will
officially come into force on October
17th of this year in June Canada became
only the second country in the world to
legalize recreational marijuana
nationwide it's also home to one of the
only securities exchanges on the planet
where people can buy stock in American
pot companies analysts estimate 44% of
the 5.7 billion dollars invested illegal
cannabis around the world come here to
Canada Canada has matured as a market
with better regulation faster and
earlier giada acquired the carson
analyzes cannabis industry data and she
fears that Canadian investors will be
scared away from putting their money in
the American market you could have a
very damaging effect to legal cannabis
businesses the United States and it
could it could do so to the point of
crippling the market what does this do
to the relations between Canadian
investors and and the United States I
think this was intended to provide a
huge chill on business travel into the
United States and I can say for myself
it's been hugely effective the US
Department of Customs and Border
Protection didn't respond when asked of
these actions are part of a new border
enforcement policy instead it notes that
marijuana remains federally prohibited
in the United States and that its
officers are thoroughly trained on
admissibility factors and that their
determinations are made on a
case-by-case basis based on the facts
and circumstances known to the officer
at the time I was helping create jobs in
the US but that's little comfort to
Sam's naima although he may be able to
get a costly in temporary waiver to his
man sometime in the future for now he's
unable to cross the world's longest
international border possibly for the
rest of his life
for CBS this morning John Blackstone
Vancouver Canada now the impact on
Canadian businesspeople is dramatic but
Americans who travel overseas and return
to the US are not affected because by
law American citizens cannot be stopped
from returning home very interesting
controversy over there